hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
hb a1c past present and future
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by abbott
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
please follow the process to obtain your
credits
by clicking on the continuing education
credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
professor philippe
gillery professor of biochemistry and
molecular biology
at the faculty of medicine of rheems
france
professor gillery you may now begin your
presentation
so welcome to this webinar
devotee to hba1c during
this lecture we will address
three topics first we will have a look
on the past
and complex history of hbr1c
and then we will review
the current challenges of hbmc
analytical and clinical ones
first the complex history of
hpr1c and a
reference of a paper that you can read
for additional information
hvr1c is one of the most powerful
biomarkers
discovered and implemented in clinical
practice
during the last five decades
the heterogeneity of human hemoglobin
was
demonstrated during the late
50s which allowed to
separate minor hemoglobins
called fast hemoglobins due to the
behavior
or hba1 made of
different fractions hp a1a
2 hb a1 e their
origin was puzzling for
many years and in
1968 an
abnormal hemoglobin was described in the
red cells
of diabetic patients and this
so-called abnormal hemoglobin was
hba1c
then the structure of hpa1
and especially hp a1c was
identified it was demonstrated that
hpa1 fractions were formed from
hb a by
a reaction called non-enzymatic
glycation they are also called
amadore products since they are formed
during
early steps of this reaction
which corresponds to the spontaneous
binding
of sugars and especially glucose
and their by-product on amino groups
of proteins among
hp01 fractions hbo1c
as shown is this example of old
chromatogram
is the major fraction it was shown
that hbo1c was formed
by binding of glucose to n-terminal
valine residues of globin beta-chance
but please note that glycation may occur
on other sites it is formed
by a cumulative and irreversible process
during all red blood cell lifespan
of about 120 days and it depends
on glucose concentration
here is a schematically represented the
structure
of hbmc on the left
part of the slide you can see a molecule
of
hba with two alpha chains and
two beta chains and the list
of the preferential glycotion sites
the most glycated site is
the beta and terminal valine of
globin beta chains and this corresponds
to hbo and c but
other sites can be glycated on both
chains alpha and beta
and another factor of heterogeneity
is the possibility that glucose binds
to one or two and terminal beta chains
but also on one or two
n-terminal alpha chains so
the term hpl1c covers
a number of molecular forms
and this underlines the necessity of a
strict
definition of hbr1c for
the standardization of assays
quickly after hbo1c discovery
hvrmc has become the gold standard of
diabetic survey
it was demonstrated by two
large-scale epidemiological studies
the dccc study for type 1 diabetes
and the uk study for type 2
diabetes both studies showed
the relationship between hpl1c
and degenerative complications of
diabetes
mellitus it was proved that
hbo1c was a reliable marker for the
optimal control of glycemic balance
hbr1c being a retrospective and
cumulative index of glycemic balance
during the four to eight eight tweaks
before sample
at that time reference values decision
limits and therapeutic targets
were established but
hbr1c values used in clinical practice
were established first using
many methods based on different
principles
and with variable analytical
performances
and second with reference
to the ngsp dccct standardization
program
which was an international program
mainly based in the united states
and using a non-specific
reference method for hbr1c
measurements
and indeed before standardization
the situation of hbo and c assays
was relatively celtic there were many
disorders
in terminologies and concepts and the
performance
of meters were highly unequal
you can see on the right part
of the slide the results of the first
quality control assessment that we
performed in france
in 1995 and
for that purpose we sent one sample
to more than 2000 laboratories
for measuring experiences the target
values
was was a six percent but
you can see that the research from
laboratories
ranged from five to eleven percent
in addition the imprecision of methods
was very high being very rarely
below five percent and very often
at 10 or even 20 percent
thus there was at that time
an indisputable need for standardization
of hb1c assays
this standardization was
internationally managed and achieved
by the international federation
of clinical chemistry and laboratory
medicine or ifcc
in this standardization process the
measurement
was clearly defined as the beta
and terminal hexapeptide so the glycati
glycated exopeptide was related to the
name glycated
and hvr1c was expressed in miniables
hpr1c
thermal hdba0 which is a major peak
of hpa plus hp a1c
the reference measurement procedure was
also described
hemoglobin was digested by
a specific enzyme which allowed
to quantify specific hexapeptides
by lcms cattle to mass spectrometry
or capillary electrophoresis
this reference measurement procedure or
lmp
is maintained by an international
icc network of approved laboratories
and this network constitutes a valid
anchor
especially for calibration of field
methods
by manufacturers the missions
of this network are to guarantee the
continuity of the
ifcc rmp and to make
hp a1c assessed
worldwide traceable to the rmp
now we can see
that after 15
years of experience there is a good
stability of values
and now all routine methods
are traceable to the icc
rmp worldwide
this hvrnc standardization is
a worldwide process with unique
and core but
the description of this method had
a side effect which is a change
in hp1c value reporting
indeed the ifcc rnp
specifically measures hp a1c
contrary to previously used national
so-called reference system like ngsp
in the usa using a
ion exchange chromatography
experience values obtained by the icc
rmp when expressed in percentage of
total levoglobin
are about 20 percent lower
than those obtained by the mgsp method
so there was a risk of confusion
and in order to avoid it ifcc proposed
to change value new expression
minimal experiences per mole hpa0 plus
hp l1c instead of
percentage of total hemoglobin
which is an expression in si units
it was possible to establish a
correlation
between the two types of expressions
using a master equation
and of course a new challenge
was the implementation of new
hp1c numbers
for example using classical units in
percentage
the reference range considered at that
time from
four to six percent of total hemoglobin
corresponding to 20 to 42
millimoles experiences per bone
hemoglobin
in this respect it was important
to have a strategy of implementation
of these new numbers and this was made
by
an icc committee
but there is still now a reporting of
units
different according to the countries
sometimes
dual reporting sometimes
only si reporting or
only ngsp reporting so there's still
a need of education and of communication
with clinical societies and patients
however what could be observed
during all this period is a continuous
improvement of method performances as
described in many papers
some examples are here and you can see
on the slide
these are the results of the cap survey
in the united states
that with time the results
obtained by the different methods
were more and more close to
the target value and that the
imprecision
of the method correctly decreased
thus the international standardization
of methods by ifcc and
the improvement of methods by
manufacturers
made a robust support
for new applications of hpr1c
assays
now we will focus
on the current challenges of hpr and css
and first
analytical ones
just a word on the methods
used today for measuring hp1c
they can measure hp1c
or total glycated hemoglobin
but in both cases due to the
traceability
to the istc rmb
or results may be expressed as hp
a1c methods measuring hp1c
can use chemical physical properties
this is the case of a category
chromatography by hplc or
capillary electrophoresis antigenicity
for immunoassay
or structural properties for enzymatic
assays and affinity methods
performed either by hplc or
automated assay measure total
glycated hemoglobin
well we can say that now there are
less and less relevant concerns
due to technical improvements of the
methods
we can now use well-controlled
automated and standardized methods
identical hdpr rnc values are obtained
due to the standardization with
most methods there are few interferences
some of them can be used in poct
and in clinical settings and there
is a global improvement of performances
together with the development of
large-scale quality
control trials
anyway there are still two types of
analytical
challenges first one how to measure
and to evaluate methods performances and
then
how to establish quality targets
if we go back to this slide showing
the results obtained before
standardization
you remember that we had very
different values and that the conclusion
was the need for standardization but
the situation observed was not only
a matter of method performances
why because
a more recent concept has appeared
which is the importance of commutability
of control materials
in external quality assessment
schemes when we consider these results
in the first approach the conclusion was
of course that methods activity
different analytical performances
and that some of them were acceptable
and other not acceptable
but if we have a more in-depth
approach we can suspect
that some differences were also
due to the non-commutability
of the materials used
commutability of control materials
is a mandatory need for
reliable information a simple
definition of commutability
could be the property of a calibration
or
control material to behave like
a fresh patient sample with a given
technique and the importance
of using this type of materials
is underlined by recommendations
for example from the iso 15
1 8 9 for
external quality assessment skills
in this equals
an important point is to establish
quality targets there are different ways
to establish quality targets but
one of the most attractive
one in my opinion is that
proposed by icc and
the group led by dr kaz feikel
this
[Music]
expression
is related to the relation between
the trueness which is the
bias of a given method
when compared to a reference
method in function
of the imprecision expressed by the
between
laboratory cv and
this representation allows
to easily see
which method are closed to the best
goal which is close to zero bias
and zero cv hardly reachable
and it's possible to evaluate the
performance of methods
in terms of bias and of
impressive
the same group has
organized a european trial
for hbr1c measurement and they sent
samples to more to
000 laboratories in 17 countries
the materials ascent were issued from
single donations and sent to the
laboratories
under three conditions fresh
frozen and lyophilized
in parallel these samples were assayed
by reference laboratories which allowed
to establish targets
for the measurement this study
demonstrated that there were
variable performances for hp
i want csas according
to countries on the top of the slide
according to manufacturers
below but also
on the type of samples
and this was more
precisely described by
an experiment that we made some
years ago
aiming at determine
the trueness of hp a1c routine assays
and in order to know
if processed eqa
materials were up to the job
so we assessed
commutability of 26
processed quality control materials
using 17 of the most fortunately used
hpr1 csas these materials
were sent to manufacturers expert
laboratories
and also to medical laboratories
this slide shows some results
overseas study on the top
it confirmed that methods
had different performances in terms of
bias and imprecision
and this scheme represents the results
obtained with
fresh whole blood
and in the lower part of the slide
we could show that there were
differences between fresh and processed
materials here you have the results
on the left you have the results of
fresh
clinical specimens in the middle
of frozen clinical specimens and
on the right side of the panel
eqa materials so you can see the
difference
of results according to the type of
sample
used and then on the
right all you can see that
various results were obtained using
different
methods and this shows
the non-commutability of some
materials it shows that if the materials
are not commutable
it is not possible to evaluate method
performances but it just
demonstrates that the material is not
convenient
for quality control trial
thus the consequences of
non-commutability
are the inability
of eqa schemes to evaluate the ability
of the different assays to provide
equivalent results and
in all cases commutability of
eqa materials should not be pursued
it should be evaluated systematically
when the goal is to evaluate dice of
assays
and or agreement between results
provided
by the different assays if commutability
has not been
evaluated the best option
is to use materials consisting
of fresh whole blood
of course if possible because
this is much more constraining
now the clinical challenge
of hp elements
there are two types
of clinical challenges now for hbos
first the situations where
hp1c results are not interpretable
this is the case for example when there
are modifications
of red blood cell lifespan
and alterations of hemoglobin metabolism
anemias transfusions hemolysis
travels of iron metabolisms
or some therapies
there are also situations where there
are discrepancies between markers of
glycemic balance
or computation between reactions
and in order to illustrate it
we will take two examples hemoglobin
variance
and renal insufficiency
the second type of challenge is
related to the new
clinical use of hbrc
classically hbot was used for the survey
of glycemic balance
but now hbo and c can be used for
diagnosis or screening
so first the situation with
complicated interpretation
again
first interference
of hemoglobin variance
on a pathophysiological point of view
hp variants may cause hemolysis and just
alter lifespan which
also alters the semiological value
of experience and all methods of course
are concerned by this point
for the analytical aspect it
depends on the method because hp
variants may interfere with the assay
and for other methods hdp variants
may pass unnoticed
when should we suspect the presence
of an hemoglobin variant
this could be an analytical argument but
it depends
again on method characteristics because
non-separative methods like automated
methods immunoassays
enzymatic methods affinity do not
evidence the variance and in the case of
separative methods iron exchange
hplc or capillary properties
the variants may be evidence or in some
cases
not so there are very different
situations according to the variant
there are also clinical arguments which
can be evoked during
the result interpretation and
a major argument is
a discrepancy between hbo and c
values and other results
each variancy value can be lower than
expected
but also can be higher than expected
of course other reasons of discrepancy
must be eliminated for example
errors in self-monitoring
results
here are examples of interferences in
capillary electrophoresis
a normal electrophoretic is shown
on the top left part of the slide with
hb1c
the major peak of hba0 and minor peaks
of hpa1
and hpa2 on
the right part you can see an example
of hpc which is
easily separated from hpe
0 and in this case hpa 1c value
can be calculated this is not the case
of hdbhope which migrates
very close to hpa0
and in the case shown no
hboc result can be calculated
but in some cases the troubles
may be much more subtle and this is a
case
of delta variance shown here as a very
minor
peak lower than one percent
in this case hp1c can be
calculated so there are various aspects
and levels of interference and in all
cases
the question is is it possible to
issue a reliable hvr1c
result
here is a second example
represented by the interference of
hbs
in sql cell disease with different
methods
there is no interference with ifcc
reference method
by lcms and also
you can see on the lower
and left part that with affinity
hplc the the variant is not detected
and there is no interference this is not
the case with capillary electrophoresis
or hplc
[Music]
cation exchange splc where the peak
is easily detected
so once again there are various types of
interferences depending on the method
and again the question
is is it possible to issue
a reliable hbonc result
in order to address this concern
how to interpret and issue a result or
a comment if it's not possible to have a
result
for the most common variants there are
databases
which can help us for example the
database of
ngsps and national glycohemoglobin
stabilization
program which gives very
interesting information about the most
common
interferences you can find here
tables with the different methods
here i have mentioned as an example only
the principle of the method
but on the website are mentioned
the names of the commercial
techniques used and you can see
the interference from hpc
hps hpe hpd labtpf
and this can help you to interpret
both of the cases when
there is a rare variant
information can be provided by
literature
and manufacturers and there are so many
variants that we cannot
go into detail today
in this lecture however in any case
if a reliable hp1c value cannot be
obtained
we have to use alternative markers like
amine or glycatid albumin if
available
second example now renal insufficiency
in patients with chronic kidney disease
and renal insufficiency
hvalc may be used but
results interpretation must be cautious
because of several specific conditions
of these diseases first
there are modifications of red blood
cell
lifespan due to chronic anemia
but also to possible a retrograde in
treatment another
phenomenon is the binding of
other adducts to hemoglobin
and this is a case of calmulation
of hemoglobin for many years
above related hemoglobin was an
analytical concern because
it interfered with many methods but
this is no more the case and now most
methods
have improved to eliminate this
interfacial
interference but this is still
a pathophysiological console
just a word about carbohydration
carbohydrate
uh corresponds to the enzymatic binding
of
isocyanic acid to proteins isothermic
acid is a natural
byproduct of urea which
spontaneously dissociates in cyanate and
isocyanic acid this isocyanic acid is
very reactive and binds to protein
and this process is increased in
patients with chronic kidney disease
because the increase of urea
so the question is is
it an interference of carbohylation
on hemoglobin glycation
in fact there is a potential
competition for the same hemoglobin
sites both isocyanic acid and glucose
are able
to bind to the beta and terminal variant
giving
either carbohydrate hemoglobin or
adpirancy
so does carbomated hemoglobin formation
interfere with experience information
and which are the consequences of hpv
values
and results interpretation for
addressing this question we have
performed an experiment in
mice we used
diabetic and uranic mice
and measured in different conditions
experience in order to determine if
there was a competition between
glycation
and carbonation here are
the results we can just look at the left
panel
hbr1c was measured in control mice
and ckd mice its varancy values
were identical about five percent
in diabetic mice hbo1c was
much higher all these results
were expected but
what is especially interesting
in that in mice with diabetes
and renal insufficiency
experience values it's much lower than
in mice
with only diabetes this
demonstrates certain communication
significantly inhibits glycation
in view and here we have plotted
hemoglobin and c values against
carbohydrate hemoglobin values in
two models of mice and
we demonstrated that when carbamility
thermoglobin increased
its virulency decreased thus
carbohylation competes with glycation
for
hbo and c formation and thus
the interpretation of hpr1c results
in patients with chronic kidney disease
must be very careful
now to finish the new indications
of hbr1c this is
a change of paradigm because
for years and decades hpr1c
was only used for monitoring
diabetes and as a biomarker
of diabetes followed but now
hbionc is also recommended
for screening or for diagnosis
and there are recommendations from who
the american diabetes association and
several national guidelines
and with hb1c it's possible
to evaluate the level of risk
from a low risk when hispanic is lower
than
39 millivolt per mole or 5.8 percent
two diabetes when it is over 47
millimole per mole
or 6.4 percent
there are advantages for i saying
hbo and c instead of glucose
in this case first and this is important
it is not needed to obtain
fasting samples then there is
a lower variability of
hp everything than of blood glucose
hb1c represent
an integrated reflect of glycemia and
there are internationally standardized
methods
with a reference network however there
are some
inconvenience
the results of hpmc
may be subjected to interferences we
have seen the examples
of hp variants and report cell
metabolism
alterations the cost of hpmc values is
higher
than that of glucose and
variations were demonstrated
according to the ethnicity this has to
be confirmed
but it could lead to the establishment
of different thresholds depending
on the population however
now hbr1c with
its role on diabetes flow
and diagnosis can be considered
a global biomarker of diabetes
now five take four messages
hvar1c is the major glycated
hemoglobin and is formed by
a non-enzymatic reaction depending
on glycine and red blood cell
lifespan hva1 csas
are standardized worldwide
they are principled to a reference
measurement procedure
maintained by the network of reference
laboratories
aspirancy assimilators exhibit generally
good performances
but eqa schemes
must prove the commutability
of control samples used
hbr1c is used not only as
a long term retrospective marker of
glycemic balance but
also as a diagnostic
markers and experience results
are interferable in most cases but
must be cautiously considered in
specific clinical situation
presence of an hp variant or a linear
impairment and
this leads us back to the first sentence
of this presentation hbo1c
is one of the most powerful biomarkers
discovered and implemented in clinical
practice
during the last five decades
thank you for your attention
well thank you professor shuleri for
your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
okay let's get started
find my questions so our first question
is it possible to discover a hemoglobin
variant in a patient
followed for many years by hp a1c
without any biological sign
yes this is a
frequent case which
highlights the necessity to know
precisely the characteristic
of the technique used as i said
some techniques are able to detect
variants
are not due to their principle
in such a situation the characteristics
of the techniques used must be
carefully checked and in most cases the
explanation
is that hb1c was initially
assayed with a non-separative technique
and then with a separative technique
able
to detect the variant thus
the choice of the technique is a
specific
prerogative of every laboratory
specialist
who must be aware of the advantages
and limitations of the method used
this does not presuppose about the
intrinsic analytical qualities of the
method but
it determines the correct interpretation
of
results
well thank you professor shilori our
next question
are there genetic factors influencing
hba1c values this is a
puzzling point which is not fully
understood
excuse me understood well
everybody this is in fact a puzzling
point
which is not fully understood it seems
that some patients have a
higher glycation rate than other ones
thus it's classical in literature to
oppose
slow or low blanketers to
fast or high glycators
thus a future strategy could be
to screen specific diabetes
associated genes in order to adapt
target values of hbinc but
these are still undergoing
investigations
and this is not yet in current practice
but this is an interesting perspective
all right thank you again professor
hillary our next
question how is it possible to survey
diabetic control
in patients homozygous for one variant
for example a patient with sickle cell
anemia
may have diabetes
well in this case obviously
hp1c cannot be assigned because
there is no hba besides
hemolysis may occur according to the
type of variant
and modify red blood cell lifespan
and the result is that the semiotical
value of
each currency is greatly
decreased so in this case the best
solution
is to assay other biomarkers
of glycemic control mainly fructose
amine
or glycated albumin this is markers
provide an information
on a shorter period
two to three weeks before the uh
the sampling but they allow a correct
follow-up
in one given patient
looks like we have time for one more
question what are the perspectives of
hba1c use in diabetes survey in the
future
well this is a very important question
i think that hb1c will remain the gold
standard
of glycemic balance especially in
patients
with a type 2 diabetes where
glycemic variations are relatively
limited in the case
of type 1 diabetes it is a little bit
different
because there are more glycemic
excursions glycemic variations
thus other strategies
may be used for assessing glycemic
control
one of them is the use of
continuous glucose monitoring
these systems allow a more dynamic view
of glycemic changes and there are
more and more frequently used by
diabetologists
in patients with type 1 diabetes
however these systems are not yet
standardized and the standardization
remained to be achieved
well thank you professor do you have any
final comments for our audience today
no i hope that the messages were clear
and that the audience was happy with
the content of the presentation and my
choices for illustrating the topic
and i thank you well thank you again
professor gillery for your time today
and for your important research
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed online
lab routes alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye